isaac le jour d'après avec tout son lot
d'interpellations et d'interrogations
tout ça des autres pour ça seulement
bonjour pascal s'attache non jours on
rappelle que vous êtes universitaire
géographie experts sur le dérèglement
climatique
on va parler de la culture du risque
parce qu'elle s'attache une notion qu'on
évoque en cas de catastrophe
vous avez entendu à droite à gauche ces
avis sur le fait que l' alerte rouge a
été déclenchée trop tôt trop longtemps
et les conséquences sur l'économie
y at il un positionnement précis pour le
curseur pascal se fâche m'écouter il est
très difficile justement d'avoir un
positionnement précis parce que imaginer
que le préfet est imaginé tout d'abord
qu'isaac était un phénomène beaucoup
plus puissants et que le préfet ait pris
une décision un peu trop tardive
les conséquences auraient été
dramatiques pour les populations pour
l'économie enfin bref les conséquences
auraient été dramatiques
donc il est très difficile si vous
voulez de choisir le bon moment le bon
instant surtout face à un phénomène
aussi désorganisé qu'isaac il faut bien
comprendre que c'est il s'agissait d'un
phénomène du d'un phénomène
dépressionnaire qui n'était pas du tout
organisé au sens où il a une trajectoire
précise on en connaît véritablement les
tenants et des aboutissants et donc il
fallait prendre une décision la décision
était prise par rapport par le préfet et
moi je crois que savez il est préférable
de prévenir que le guérir donc il est
préférable à la rigueur et je comprends
les entrepreneurs qui disent on a perdu
une journée de travail et qui nous la
rendre à je peux entendre ce discours
mais moi je préfère quand même à la
rigueur que les populations soient
préservés et qu'on ait perdu une journée
de travail mais qui ait pas de morts
la formation des citoyens sur les
risques naturels et technologiques
majeurs c'est un droit codifié parce qu
elle se fâche c'est un maillon essentiel
de la prévention des risques naturels et
technologiques
elle doit permettre aux citoyens de
connaître les dangers auxquels il est
exposé les dommages prévisible les
mesures préventives qui peut prendre
pour réduire sa vulnérabilité ainsi que
les moins de protection et de secours
mises en oeuvre par les pouvoirs publics
pour ce qu'on a vu quasiment tout était
fait pour isaac
mais tout a été fait pour isoler que
c'était vraiment moi je crois que
c'était vraiment un exercice grandeur
grandeur nature grandeur réelle et c'est
en ce sens que c'est intéressant parce
que après les deux ouragans que nous
avons vécu dirons-nous même s'il ne nous
ont pas frapper directement derrière
maria nous sommes encore confrontés à un
phénomène
enfin risques naturels majeurs et je
crois que c'est très intéressant parce
que c'est intéressant et dieu merci il
n'y a pas eu il ya peu de victimes n'y a
pas eu de dégâts
donc c'est très intéressant dans la
mesure où ça permet aux populations
d'être toujours maintenu sous tension si
j'ose dire et donc d'intégrer cette
culture du risque qu'il nous faut de
toute façon avec laquelle il nous faut
vivre
je rappelle quand même qu'après dean en
2007 nous sommes restés longtemps sans
avoir de véritable exercice de ce type
ou en tout cas de mise en situation
hélas deux années enfin les deux années
qui se suivent deux exercices ou trois
exercices même grandeur nature je crois
que c'est très très bien pour la mémoire
du récit pour la la connaissance et pour
le le fait que la population intègre un
certain nombre de comportements vont
multiplier les conférences les
rencontres pour échanger de la
population martiniquaise parce qu'à sa
phase questions très simples
cette culture du risque est elle
suffisamment ancrées dans l'esprit des
martiniquais de façon objective
très concrètement non mais il n'empêche
que l'on sent petit à petit un sursaut
on sent un frémissement la population et
si vous voulez intègre assez rapidement
les bons comportements à condition une
fois de plus qu'il y ait des exercices
réguliers alors ce qu'on a vécu avec
isaac ce n'était pas un exercice était
véritablement le phénomène mais qui a
été joué si j'ose dire comme un exercice
et on peut voir que haut niveau au
niveau de l'état mais aussi au niveau
d'un certain nombre d'associations qui
ont joué leur rôle
mais tout le monde est prêt en tout cas
en cas en cas de qatargas 2 voilà de
survenue de risques naturels majeurs
d'aléas naturels
bon maintenant il faut véritablement que
ce qui s'est passé avec isaac ne
démobilise pas la population parce que
c'est ça le risque il y à il ya un
double risque il ya le risque en tant
que tel en tant qu aller à le phénomène
lui-même
et puis il ya le fait que comme le
phénomène annoncé n'est pas n'a pas été
à la hauteur de ce que les uns et des
autres estimait que les populations se
démobilisent qu'il faut véritablement la
faire passer ce message c'est que en
dépit de ce qui s'est passé hier et vaut
mieux que ça se soit passé ainsi
mais les uns et des autres doivent être
conscients que nous vivons sur un
territoire à risque que dans les années
à venir de toute façon ce type de
phénomène va être de plus en plus
fréquent est de plus en plus
violent et donc il nous faut de toute
façon être toujours sous tension si
j'ose dire est sous tension c'est-à-dire
être prêts à agir rapidement pour
protéger nos vies protéger je veux dire
notre environnement et tout ce que tout
ce qu'on nous a tous ceux dont nous
disposons cette culture du risque elle
passe par l'action de l'état vous l'avez
dire par les services publics par des
associations également par notre
capacité individuelle personnelle aller
chercher l'information aussi bien
évidemment il faut il faut bien qu'il
faut bien comprendre que si l'état nous
doit
si vous voulez un service à l'état est
là pour assurer la l'ordre public la
sécurité la sécurisation des populations
etc
il est évident que les uns et les autres
ne doivent pas attendre un peu comme des
oisillons que ça tombe du ciel où ils
doivent pas attendre la becquée il faut
véritablement que les 1,2 soit proactif
et aille chercher l'information et
surtout soit aussi des sortes de relais
moi je crois que dans les quartiers il
faut que les uns et les autres mais
c'est un peu lent trade qui existaient
de par le passé en martinique
on savait que madame untel était par
exemple grabataire ou qu'intel ne
pouvait pas je ne sais pas mais ces
fameuses listes des personnes
vulnérables rogatoire par la liste
nationale des mairies tout à fait mais
c'est exactement ça en fait on est on
est dans la logique de ce qui existait
avant mais qui n'était pas codifié
maintenant ça l'est mais il faut
véritablement que dans les quartiers les
uns et les autres
enfin fasse preuve de solidarité et que
voilà l'entr'aide joue totalement aller
chercher l'information parce que ça se
sache et on rappelle que vous êtes
universitaire donc vous êtes au contact
de cette jeunesse martiniquaise aller
chercher l'information ce n'est pas non
plus gober avaler tout ce qui se dit sur
what's up et sur facebook alors sûrement
pas alors là c'est clair que sur
facebook sans fin sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez pour parler
familièrement à boire et à manger il ya
un peu tout et n'importe quoi tout et le
contraire de tout donc il faut de toute
façon à être avoir un esprit critique
pour faire un peu loterie de toute façon
il faut bien que les choses soient
claires les seules informations qui sont
fiables ce sont celles qui sont données
par les autorités donc celles qui ont
autorité pour donner l'information
c'est-à-dire les services bombes les
services de la préfecture les services
de météo france
les pompiers etc les services de police
et s'est ensuite sur what's app et sûre
sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez
véritablement des informations qui
circulent alors ce sont soit des fake ou
où certains s'amusent
tout cas il faut véritablement faire le
tri entre les bonnes informations et
puis ceux qui voient là sont là pour
s'amuser
la culture du risque c'est du binaire
c'est tout ou rien c'est du noir du
blanc
il n'y a pas 50 millions ce possible non
malheureusement la culture du rif c'est
vrai que ça peut être vécu comme quelque
chose d'assez comment dirais-je d' assez
binaire
c'est soit on suit soit sur soi on suit
les consignes ou on ne suit pas et donc
on est on est or on est hors circuit
bon c'est vrai que ça peut être vécu
comme cela il n'empêche qu'il ya
toujours de toute façon bond de 2
petites nuances on peut toujours ici ou
là adapter un peu les choses mais il
faut quand même que la population
comprenne que la meilleure façon de
protéger sa sas afin de protéger sa vie
et de protéger celle de son entourage
c'est quand même de respecter les
consignes de sécurité qui sont édictées
par les services par les services
étatiques
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen fin il
prône espagne en a pas d'autres on n'a
pas inventé d'autres c'est le respect
des consignes de sécurité
et je crois qu'en martinique c'est très
important quand jeudi en martinique
c'est dans les petites antilles de façon
générale toutes les études qui ont été
menées le l'indiquent nous n'avons pas
une grande mémoire collective nous
n'avons pas n'avons pas encore intégré
vraiment cette culture du risque qui
pourtant fait partie de notre quotidien
mais pour des raisons que les
psychologues pour être facilement
expliquer nous avons un peu un certain
détachement une certain recul vis-à-vis
de ces choses il nous faut de plus en
plus dans les années à venir apprendre à
être attentifs apprendre à être préparés
et c'est comme tout ça s'apprend surtout
qu'avec phénomène cyclonique
il ya eu isaac ces dernières heures il
ya toute une palette de situations
énorme
les spécialistes l'habitude eux mêmes ne
sont pas ne savent pas tout mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre tout d'abord
c'est que la météorologie n'est pas une
science exacte et un ep elle est
d'autant moins une science exacte d'un
je veux dire en milieu tropical et
particulièrement en milieu tropical
micro insulaire parce que sur nos
territoires c'est pas du tout comme en
france hexagonale où les données
climatiques qu'il s'avère nécessaire
donc si vous voulez d'appréhender elles
sont quand même relativement fixes et on
les connaît et donc les prévisions sont
quand même très facile à faire en milieu
tropical est particulièrement mis en
milieu micro insulaire vous avez battre
in pléthore de fac
alors qu'il faut prendre en
considération et en plus le relief n'est
pas puisqu'on est surnommé sur m6 on et
territoires avec des reliefs extrêmement
tourmenté et le relief peut être aussi
un facteur qui va faire que il va
pleuvoir à tel endroit et pas telle
autre alors qu'on avait dit qu'il ne
pleuvrait pas où on avait dit qu'il
pleuvrait et puis tout compte fait il y
en a eu de pluie enfin c'est très
compliqué de faire des prévisions
météorologiques au milieu micro
insulaire est particulièrement milieu
tropical et je crois qu'il faut vraiment
pas jeter la pierre à météo france
ils font véritablement du mieux possible
ça je peux en attester je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas fonctionnaire ou un voile
employa météo france mais je sais ce
qu'ils font et je sais qu'ils font du
mieux possible est vraiment face à des
phénomènes aussi désorganisé qu'isaac et
vu les moyens dont nous disposons
enfin le nécessaire a été fait par météo
france mais une fois de plus la
météorologie n'est pas une science
exacte
en termes de culture du risque sur la
dernière question parce qu elle se fâche
s'il faut appuyer un bouton prendre
conseils pour prendre une urgence de
situation serait croire qu est ce que
serait la première chose à faire en
termes de culture du risque en termes de
culture du risque je crois qu'il faut
que la population atteinte qu'elle doit
être proactive c'est à dire qu'elle doit
aussi au delà de toutes les informations
qui lui sont données par les services de
faim les services étatiques
il faut véritablement que la population
à y chercher l'information et donc il y
a très souvent des conférences grand
public et c'est vrai qu'on ne croise pas
beaucoup de monde
ou alors on en croise toujours les mêmes
personnes mais je crois que c'est
véritablement ce à être proactifs merci
parce que ça fâche universitaire
géographe merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin dans son crédit sur cette notion
de culture du risque bonne journée
[Musique]